يعني الاعلام الصهيوني
اثار موضوع ايصال الدواء لاسرى العدو كما
تفضلت السؤال انا اود ان اوضح انه اخلاقيا
وقيمياً لذلك قيمنا واخلاقنا تحتم علينا
ان نقدم العلاج اللازم للاسرى وانا اذكر
ايضا ان تحدثنا في مؤتمر صحفي قبل مده عن
نقل احد الجنود الجرحى الى مستشفى لعلاجه
رغم المخاطر الامنيه المترتبه على ذلك
طبعا احنا بنعالج الاسرى ونتنياهو يقتلهم
بالقصف توفير الدواء مساله فيها بعد
انساني بلا شك ونحن
نوفر مما يتيسر لنا وما موجود عندنا لكن
مع الحصار ومنع الدواء
و هذا امر بات معروفا
للجميع وايضا مع الالحاح من قبل قياده
الحركه في ادخال الدواء من اجل شعبنا
الفلسطيني في ظل ضغط ايضا عائلات الاسرى
عرض الاحتلال ارسال ادويه تتعلق بهؤلاء
الاسرى هذا الامر فيه مشكلتين الاولى احنا
نعتقد ان شعبنا يحتاج الى الدواء وهو اولى
بهذا الدواء والمساله الثانيه هناك مشكله
يعني لا تخفى على احد في بعدها الامني
وحساسيه موضوع الاسرى ولذلك كان ردنا اننا
حريصون على علاجهم ولكننا سنعالج بما
يتوفر من دواء يصل لشعبنا هنا احنا بنشكر
الاشقاء في قطر الذين بادروا لارسال
ويبادر لارسال
ادويه في ظل مخاطر عديده تتهدد حياه شعبنا
وما يصل من دواء
سيكون جزء منه لعلاج او سيعالج بعض
الاسراء بما يصل من هذا الدواء وانا اؤكد
هنا انه لا خطر من طرف المقاومه على
الاسرى الخطر الوحيد الذي يهدد الاسرى هو
او حياه الاسرى هو نتنياهو ووزير حربه
وجيشه الذي قتل عيانا جنو اسرى بعد لجوئهم
اليه